first I want to get into a little lesser
profile game but I'm sure people are
interested in nonetheless berserk band
of the hawk yeah mmm you wanted to talk
about this I want to because I don't
know my favorite game you two both
played it right yeah a couple hours a
little bit yeah yeah so it's based on I
like a more than 27 year running manga
series I said manga before the show
again Kelly yelled at me yeah rightfully
so wait so describe this series to me
quick before we jump into the game Oh
fine you don I don't know uh I mean it's
yours berserkers the series band of the
hot serious bruise irk okay um it's
known for being really gory um it kind
of resurfaced due to a new anime that
aired last year and it was controversial
for having a lot of CG that everyone
hated is basically all soon it was like
all CG um but yeah it's like as opposed
to like purist anime well that yeah cuz
there was a TV series in the 90s that
was rather short lived only told like
part of one Ark of the money yeah and it
didn't didn't go that far it's one of
those things that like some anime I'll
be like just read the manga this is
probably one of them for me but it's
about a dude named guts and he just
likes to kill people that's a super
simplification of it yeah there's like a
lot of occult stuff thats brought into
it and super gory and you know like
things like demons and hell are very
prominent i mean like i want to
emphasize how gory and heavy it is like
you this is not something you take
lightly don't read it like you just want
to like a little rump you know really
fits because it's part of like it was a
spinoff of the warrior series dynasty
warriors weirdly similar to that series
right moose oh yeah coz Omega force did
this as well right yeah and uh speaking
yeah and berserk has got her guts has
got a huge sword and he's just mowing
down enemies and that's basically what
you've always done in the friends and
our review is up if you want to go read
it five five five out of ten from Miguel
concepts you own or editor here at
gamespot he seemed to find a monotonous
and banal after its first hour or two
actually considering the like extra
content yeah that's very much a common
complaint
but this one has a lot of anime
cutscenes in it um we're just looking at
some berserk right now uh super long
cutscenes right super long cutscenes
taken from the long history of different
anime and different arcs of berserk and
they actually did tighten up the CG that
was a big complaint for the most recent
berserk anime adaptation which I thought
was interesting but yeah yeah look at
that those upturned lips and that all
this nose is not the guts I know that's
not the bill he looks different than the
one we used to you or slightly yeah
there's like stylized yeah take on them
and so like you know it's the anime
itself is engaging like the cutscenes
are enjoyable to watch despite like yeah
I love the older stuff but these are
still okay in the context of the game
but they only get about five to ten
minutes to play before you get thrown
into another cutscene oh that's like
what games asuras wrath did you play
that back in the day yeah yeah that a
little bit but even that like the
gameplay itself was quick time events
right exactly interacts death scene is
about the whole game but like to
contrast it with something similar like
I've played one piece Musso games that
basically tell a very abridged version
of the 1p story if you don't know one
piece is that like episode 800 now
really um still running uh he has too
many um but like the one piece Musso
games kind of do these very short
versions of cutscenes and so it's not as
broken up as mana the hawk is just for
context okay so there are like side
objectives it looks like in this from
what you guys played how long did both
you play I was already allowed to play
about two hours yeah every only allowed
who was preventing you from playing one
the TR company Oh like a preview I was
doing capturing footage I I thought like
you are part of PETA to play more than
an hour bezerk a heavy know you're
really
Peter that games rated M get off me I
want to watch my stories yep that's how
you played it for a preview which is
that you same thing or do you play it
like post-release well I sit out I yet
yes I sit next to Miguel so I just kind
of swoop in on what he's he's working on
sometimes room so I didn't even get two
hours ok it's enough with a mousou game
you like it's pretty much enough to get
a feel for what it's going to be a the
gameplay is pretty similar throughout
obviously and I watched a lot of the
cutscenes to kind of over his shoulder
what's going on here is it like a
medieval kind of aesthetic yes sort of I
mean like you're you were kind of like
an orphan and now you're a mercenary and
you joined this this crew that is
essentially a the leader is at Griffith
is sort of is like your longtime like a
lie rebel from that point forward but
you know like the gameplay is basically
this no matter what your side objectives
are this is kind of all you're doing
yeah and in a sense it does kind of
capture like the essence of guts like
he's covered in blood right now there's
blood flying everywhere has his huge
sword right it makes a lot of sense it
makes a lot of sense and I think maybe
perhaps better than the berserk games
that were on dreamcast and the Japanese
one on ps2 like this feels like your
your your guts a little bit more but it
just you don't really get the same sense
of like the character rather than like
what he does mm-hmm agency character in
the manga he's certainly conflicted he's
got a lot of inner dialogue yeah you
kind of get a lot of it here just
through cutscenes which is ambitious for
these games to try to like you know
present a story but it's especially for
fans of the series stuff they've already
seen so it does a retread familiar
ground which yes the tracks from that a
little bit hmm and there's certain
aspects of the anime and manga that are
hinted at or sort of talked about for
brief stints of time even in those
mediums that it's like a video game that
was exploring just like the Dark Knight
part of guts would be awesome but it
focuses so much in the beginning well
actually in the very beginning he's in
like hell yeah but from that point
forward it moves towards him like you
know being a budding mercenary and that
stuff bezerk fans have experienced
forever and I think this doesn't even
give them what they want and speaking as
a casual berserk fan it doesn't give me
what I want yeah and even like if you're
like this isn't going to be a good entry
point for berserk if you haven't been
exposed to it at all
again just read the manga that's my
mantra so I don't know how much of a
dedicated following like Michelle games
have I mean I'm sure they do but it
seems like so monotonous and I'm I feel
like I'm [ __ ] on it all I I played
them i will I play them for like the
catharsis of it just kind of mowing
through enemies and yes like that were
relaxing kind of grind sure it is this
game cater well to fans amoo stehlik
even if they don't care about so Gil has
a pretty long history with the series I
forget his exact points but basically I
think what he would have boiled down to
for him is in that context this doesn't
maybe do enough to stand out if you're
just looking at it as like a mousou game
yeah I just speaking from my experience
if you look at attack on titan that game
that came out a couple months ago at
least that point mobility has changed
because you have these things that
propel you 3d maneuver gear right like
you can just fly all around the map I
mean that feels like a fundamental
change where it's like cool this really
it talked about the ps4 01 yeah yeah I
mean this really just feels like you're
playing with so with the dressing of
berserk not necessarily that it's
influenced the gameplay as much as the
story in a setting that's a good point
gotcha okay well that is berserk band of
the hawk will move on from that shortly
I review by Miguel conception is up on
gamespot gave it a five out of ten you
can go read a little more about that we
have gameplay videos up as well if
you're in this video anymore yeah the
video reviews up on YouTube and GameSpot
so go check those out and let us know
what you think and whether you want to
be playing it amid the slew of releases
on the near horizon slurry real frothy
scary
[Music]
you